Okay Michael.
So here's the definition of
the reward function (s, o).
It's an expectation over
the set of rewards that
I'm going to see discounted
at each step by gamma.
So the first reward that I see,
r1 step one, is going to be R.
In Step two, it's going to
be R 2 discounted by gamma.
In step three, it's going to be
R 3 discounted by gamma squared.
And so on and so forth,
until the option ends after K steps.
And that final reward will be
discounted by gamma to the K minus 1.
>>
>> So this is in some sense the average,
in fact in a very particular sense
this is the average discounted reward
that I will see by executing this
option in this particular state.
Does that make sense?
>> Yes I mean it's I guess it's weird
because it's kind of immediate reward
in the sense that it's the reward that
comes from executing that one option.
But it's also clearly not immediate
reward it's a sum of rewards.
>> Right, so one way of thinking about
this is remember all an option is
a policy that I'm going to execute.
That policy will be realized in
specific actions which means it
will be realized in
a particular states and
rewards that I will see a bunch of
source, source, source, source.
So even though from the outside,
I start here in this particular state.
Some time passes I end up in this state.
What's actually happening along
the way is I'm visiting every single
one of these states and
picking up reward along the way.
But we need to be able
to discount that reward.
And so the discount factor is hidden
inside of the reward function.
So this is as if rather
than executing the option.
I had actually just executed all
the atomic actions at the option itself.
Will in fact execute.
>> And then you'll call that
sort of one bolus of reward?
>> Right because all that's
really happening right is that
>> Whenever you have this kind of
summation over you taking you seeing
a bunch of states and taking a bunch of
actions, all you're doing is adding up
all the rewards you're going to see.
Remember we got the bellman
equation by just writing out that
we're going to visit
a whole bunch of rewards.
That the definition of the value of
being in the state is the expected
discount of reward.
So we're keeping that consistent
here in this in this abstracted
temporally abstract actions setting
by virtue of the fact that still
the immediate rewards are discounted.
According to the true time steps of
the underlying process even though we,
I guess as the agent get to think at
a higher level we get to think about
an action taking multiple steps.
>> Right, exactly and so
we do something very similar for F and
we end up with this nice equation.